call the division to uh meeting to
order and invite the Lottery Commission
Folks up to talk about the lottery
budget and perhaps after you introduce
yourselves you could tell us how you're
going to go through so people that are
watching might understand where the flow
following okay um good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee um my
name is Charlie McIntyre I'm the
director of the Hampshire lottery I've
had the privilege of being that for
almost 15 years now uh and with me today
is my colleague our Chief Financial
Officer Jim durus um essentially Mr
chairman if it please the committee I
was going to go through a very brief
couple of slides to present both what is
our graph of our revenues versus
expenses and then obviously our revenues
by product um and then uh obviously
explain briefly each of the products we
sell
and then um answer any questions I don't
expect this to be a long process I know
you folks may have a lot of questions
given the nature of what we do and how
we do it and why um well I know the why
it's money
U um but I I our budget is very simple
so that's essentially the process Mr
chairman if you want me to
proceed sure did you bring some tickets
fors par did you bring some tickets for
us then you would have to file paper
yeah I was going to say you you got to
ask ahead of time you really you just
got no please proceed of course um
certainly a very basic the first slot
obviously is an introductory one the
second one is um essentially our
expenses and profitability over the last
decade um and I can say actually going
back further when I first started at New
Hampshire lottery in 2011 our return to
education trust fund of $62 million in
FY 24 it was 207 million so we have more
than tripled uh the net profitability to
the state and as you see the expenses
they virtually remain flat the entire
time um and as you can
imagine we run very much like a
business our divisions are very much set
up like business divisions sales
marketing Security Finance uh we have a
compliance Department um investigations
and enforcement department uh and so
it's set very much like a business to
run like a business and as you folks
well know we are the I don't know if
we're the most audited agency in the
state but we're close if we're not um
annually the LBA audit team is there for
five months a year and they do our they
go over our books um they review our
annual report which is this
document um which um we don't send to
everybody because it's a lot of paper um
but it's available on our website uh
which I think was I just probably
hijacked your question Mr chairman no I
just to say I think it's also available
on the uh on the LBA website yeah and
certainly they audit and um if you're
interested next month we go before uh
fiscal for our um review of the findings
the um lb audit team had so uh our
numbers are scrubbed as M as the most of
any agency in the state um rightfully so
didn't we already see you this year you
received yeah the report but there's a
follow-up management letter ah okay that
comes uh and there's a few findings I'll
look forward to
that I would point out that none of them
relate to actually the finances as our
CFO would be happy to point out but none
relate to the actual the math of things
um uh and so certainly one of the points
I try and raise particularly with house
finance and Senate Finance is um while
revenues and expenses are two different
committees they're two sides of the same
C point and so please when you what you
do here impacts Revenue down the hall to
your colleagues and so that's one of the
reasons I asked you to review this slide
and certainly contained within the
governor's budget is an increased
Revenue estimate for FY uh 26 and 27
$185 million which is a little over 12
million more annually than had been in
the uh Revenue estimates for house
andent Ways and Means from the fall of
last year and so we we've raised
guidance essentially someone reading
this wrong it looks like your revenues
are going down in the next in the next
few years so the revenues are going down
so two so FY 24 was an absolute high
water mark where everything hit
perfectly great and what I mean by that
is we had annual sales of Powerball our
record year far and away because we had
a record number of billion dooll
jackpots and the reason we had a record
number of billion dollar jackpots is
because interest rates went up so the
jackpot size is a function of the amount
of cash we have on hand multiplied by a
bond factor which is interest rate
driven equals jackpot size so where that
ratio is usually 1.4 1.5 so cash in hand
times 1.4 it was 2.2 2.3 2.4 and so we
had a number of billion- dollar jackpots
which is great for
marketing uh and we are you know I'm
proud to say the number one jurisdiction
in the country for Powerball sales per
what but it's certainly a source of
Pride because everyone sells that ticket
the same way across the country and the
fact that we do it the best is an
obviously a matter of Pride for the
staff and um kudos to the folks that I
we work with um but it was a perfect
storm and we're the number one at it and
so there was a large profitability and
every Powerball ticket we sell 40 cents
that is profit so so every dollar 40
cents is profit so for us it's our
highest margin ticket we sell uh and so
a dollar there is worth two and change
in a scratch ticket sale so that's why
it's our sales are going up it's just in
what we make the most profit in is going
down through no fault of ours it's just
the nature of Powerball it's jackpots
over a billion dollars are like three
foot snow storms they show up when they
show up I can't the ping pong balls
don't have a memory I can't affect them
um and so that's our Revenue um picture
for the next two years and the remainder
of this year and obviously the last
slide is a breakdown of or the second
last slide is a breakdown of where our
sales come
from and as you can see majority of our
gross sales still come from scratch
tickets um but containing within this
graph and within the table within it is
um essentially all of our revenue
and I'll pause for any questions at this
point this is represent papovich thank
you Mr chair and thank you for being
here um is that gross revenue or the um
net you know the profit sure it's
actually a it's it's a gross revenue but
in some cases like for scratch tickets
this is gross revenue before prizes are
paid out and in the case of um
pardon an i lottering sports betting
that's net of prizes before expenses are
factored in if I mean I don't know how
much extra work would it be to also have
a similar chart with the you know
profits per game let's say leaving out
the you know budget that you actually
spend the 11 million whatever you pay
for staff never mind that overhead
because there is no point in allocating
it but just in terms of the gross profit
per product yeah it's certainly I'm sure
it's somewhere in a report yeah it is I
mean certainly we don't break out uh as
you can imagine we try
in cross product staff so a number of
like my colleague here Jim does the
finances for all the buildings so I
don't factor out him but certainly we
can get you a close approximation
representative of what it is profit per
um product line um as a as
a yeah you write that down s forget it
yeah page
4 Page
4 suiz oh okay actually my if look at
page 42 of the in report on our website
U it does a
breakdown no followup needed we're good
with that thank you all
right
um and certainly um the gross sales have
gone up dramatically since 10 years ago
we were around $250 million in gross
sales now it's 633 million in gross
sales and it will continue to go up
um I wanted to bring your attention to
the prioritized needs that we put in for
the budget and uh certainly the for the
committee's consideration of um putting
it back in the budget one is to update
our security system which is outdated
and
um it's not compatible with our existing
infrastructure I think the cameras are
running on Windows 7 if I'm not
mistaken um which has has no longer been
patched since 2012 maybe
15 okay yeah
it's it's uh and it runs its own PC uh
in its own server its own house because
it's older um and then
um obviously upgrades to our ex um
entrance way to make it more ADA
Compliant it's not particularly ADA
Compliant the door is too hard to open
and the the ramp is not perfect uh and
so those are just two needs we have I
mean there were a number of needs that
were met in the budget um but those two
uh were additional as well
um to be sure I think our budget is
straightforward um so before you go
beyond that sure so you're running a
single IBM Windows 7 machine right now
correct that's running the security
system the rest of the the rest of the
operation is based on oit it's through
oit and that that's up to date but the
security system is running off a single
server managing uh um the cameras that
surveil the building your own building
correct our own building yes oh what do
you need those for pardon what do you
need that for you don't any money there
do
you no it's it's gold bars in the
basement so um we have neighbors who
have set up camp in a abandoned lot next
to us and in some cases it varies
between five and 50 um homeless folks
who um come visit our building uh use
our water spigot um and I we did not as
a matter of courtesy and just out of
humanity um did not put a lock on the
spigot it's August I'm not going to let
these folks die Heats you know heat
stroke because we don't so um but you
know we do need security for the
building itself people do think honest
to God we had a jackpot of I think it
was half a billion dollars and it was
400 million in cash and I swear they
thought that we had the money in the
building
like where do you keep that money I'm
like you know what in a lock room yeah
okay but but on a serious note because I
actually I'm a Macintosh guy but I have
to have a PC for some stuff that I do
and I'm like you I'm way back there yeah
since it's only controlling your cameras
what what's the what's your concern
about having the fact that the software
is out of date it's G to die eventually
I mean certainly we had two old
firewalls that run our um run our
firewalls and the servers and they were
both 10 years old we turned them off and
they both died immediately so clearly
there was embedded in that firewall a
kill after so many years because we
don't want to sell them more and so at
some point where're fearful it's not
going to work okay but when you say
firewall the way you just described it
it sounds like you turned off a router
no it was a it was a sorry different
different products different so there
were firewalls in our computer room this
is a different this system is different
the surveillance system we're requesting
is different thing I my fear is that we
turn it off one day move it it won't go
back on and then now now the
surveillance system is dead okay I mean
I I I just got to say $100,000 for a PC
sounds an awful lot of money I think
it's also an upgrade it's excuse me to
interrupt that but this would be an
upgrade to the whole system it would be
getting cameras that aren't 30 years old
as well um and fewer cameras than we
have now modernizing it getting it into
where and one of the risks is when it's
on a single PC like this theoretically
if something happened and someone took
that computer there's no backing up
there's nothing on the server to show
what happened that night um this is a
standalone piece if that computer goes
and something
happens you have nothing you have
nothing to view what happened with it
got it but you can buy two PCS for a lot
less 100 Grand it's a whole system but
and also help me understand what a whole
system is you're just controlling a
couple of cameras sorry I just your
question but um it was also upgrade the
front sales office in terms of physical
plant um right now the public see inside
our buildings through glass doors and um
there's no security for the sales office
the glass is not Bulletproof the walls
aren't bulletproof and uh every so often
we have a situation that's remarkably
uncomfortable for our sales staff um
where one of two things happens one is
somebody thinks they won and they didn't
win said that again someone thinks they
won and they didn't win okay they
thought it was a one and it's actually a
10 or whatever or two and more
aggressively is we're required to offset
Child Support Enforcement payments so if
you are um in a rears in child support
and you come and win we have to grab
that money even though in some instances
you may have already paid it just not
has gotten through the system and those
folks tend to be
unhappy fair enough but so how does this
help that problem so it was U it's both
surveillance in terms of the the
equipment the servers the um cameras but
also to add a layer of security to the
front office harden up the wall that
sits below waste level uh for our
employees as well as change the doors to
not be clear glass looking into our
offices so that's not the access that's
not the $30,000 piece no that's not is
it oh it
is no no it's ADA
is thought it was
important
sales that system that number is a
estimate given to us
by was it
which 100,000 yeah
okay that Mak be even more suspicious I
just got to tell you um well okay you
know we're in a tipe budget situation of
course anything you can do to yeah but
absolutely no I apologize for not having
a better knowledge of it so not a
problem represent
thank you Mr chair and again sorry for
stepping out for a moment I got a phone
call that whoever called me should have
known better than to call me during a
hearing um and they were told that so um
I have a different question I'm U you
know you started by saying that the you
know expenses didn't change that much
and uh obviously the graph when you look
at the revenues they are very long lines
but when you look at the shorter lines
and the actual operating expenses from
2022 which admittedly is kind of a low
Watermark to
2025 it's 3 years and a 76% increase in
operating expenses now obviously you
didn't come here with all the details in
that but I would like to have a very
thorough understanding of why you know
the increases are quite that steep in
operating expenses I'm sure you have
good reasons I would just like to
understand them because as the chairman
was saying and frankly we've been saying
it to everybody and every it's a tight
budget here and
we appreciate the many dollars you put
into the education trust fund but
expenses still need to be scrutinized
obviously with an eye towards not U you
know robbing Peter to pay Paul and
saving a dollar in expenses to lose 10
in Revenue right so we are keenly aware
of that but um it is still a sharply
climbing year-over-year number from 2022
to 2025 projected and we'd really want
to understand at least I would want to
understand and way more detail on what
drives it what is essential and so on
and so forth sure certainly if you U
remember the negotiate to collect a
bargain agreement uh 10% 10% 10% um is
that we also added a number of employees
because we um the this body and the
governor agreed to allow charitable
gambling rooms to add historic horse
racing and so that now has 20 2400
gaming machines in the state and that
number is going to increase by 1,500 in
the next three weeks so you're talking
now 4,000 gaming machines so we have to
we increased our regulatory footprint
our investigators our licensing
footprint I said I'm sure to have good
reasons I would just like to better
understand the Steep increase right yeah
of course some some issues we're aware
of some we are not and we need to
understand and honestly one of the also
things is because we've increased
revenues um one of the hard hardest
things to do in a businesses scale up
obviously and we've increased
advertising significantly I think we
increased it 20% um over the last budget
versus this current bium uh just to
support the growth as you can imagine we
have a number of
additional verticals we didn't have 10
years ago we have Internet we have
sports betting we have
um just a number of things we have to
add and honestly advertising got more
expensive because of the number of
channels you can advertise through um
you can do so just
it's have full-time folks who nothing
but social media because it's a constant
stream of of data um our benefits would
up
by yes about a simar about payroll and
then doit was a significant expense
because we are trying to launch a um
Salesforce application for the lottery
itself to maintain a customer database
of folks who call in have issues um up
until well still we use pen and paper we
use notepads emails texts so and so
called we don't have a tracking system
of that um and so that was an additional
expense as well that was approved in the
last Bal budget so um but I could
certainly get them line by line
representive to your point if you want
um but those are the four of the main
ones that all derived large and it was
meant to support the business and sort
of be more customer friendly I
appreciate the color commentary and of
course more details and I understand
it's a followup item we didn't I didn't
expect you to just no of course you know
go into that detail I just want you to
know that I would like to yeah of course
no and certainly not just discounting
the fact that expenses matter uh and I
can tell you as a in a global sense
we've never spent our
budget not once not ever have we ever
spent every dollar that was allocated
and it one of the reasons is because the
the budgeting purpose here it's really
just a paper entry because we spend from
our own Revenue stream and so if we
don't spend it it means it returns to
profit and
so if we don't think it's going to drive
Revenue growth we don't spend it and I
can suggest you in terms heartily that
my colleague to my right is the most
conservative spender of money that has
ever graced the the good Lord's Earth
so like all
CFOs did I hear you say you added
employees correct we had so when uh well
we we've always had the positions that
were funded we just filled them when oh
they you've had four vacancies correct
we've always had vacancies and we just
didn't fill them until we needed them
and then we really needed them so no
vacancies now well we have vacancies now
we have 13 positions
vacant and are they funded or unfunded
um they're all funded they're all funded
and is there any plan
to fill
them um certainly yes but not as if yet
we're trying to like I said we're going
through cycles and there are two gaming
rooms that are coming online the next
three weeks one in Rochester and one in
dasua which is very large um and we're
trying to get through the operational
phase of launching them and then see
thereafter what's needed in terms of
maintaining them regulating them um so
the short answer is yes but not by date
certain do you have any idea what
they're funded
at no funded in terms of well the funded
positions they must have a dollar amount
Associated oh yeah yeah but I had of
honest know they were investigator I
think is a labor grade
20 sorry okay anyway yeah I think it's
23 but they end up being usually for us
almost exclusively ex law enforcement
from other states sort of retired police
officers from other states end up being
our
investigators represent
can you tell me how many employees do
you have right
now we have 84 employees but that
currently uh but that includes our three
Commissioners so really it's 81
employees who are operationally working
at the
lottery do they all can I follow up yes
do they all work in your facility in
this facility um so no it's a we have
two we have two offices we have the
Lottery headquarters which is on
integral drive we have a regional office
which really houses houses the majority
of our investigations and enforcement
Division and then we have a number of
employees whose job to be on the road
okay thank
you what was the total you
gave 81 plus three commission yeah so
our commission is really just a board of
directors okay so 80 plus you're a
commissioner yeah this they have the
title commissioner but really it's not
like a real I don't see real they're
very real but uh they don't act like
other Commissioners um I'm just trying
to get an accurate account cuz they you
have 93 employees and then you take away
13 vacancies that comes to 80 yeah and
the commissioner is not an employee or
the 81st person they're paid but it's a
it's a stipend it's not like a full-time
employee they're paid I think the chair
is paid 20,000 and the three two other
Commissioners I think get 12,000 in year
position carry on uh and certainly no to
that point um as you can see from our
budget the large increases have been
really based around payroll o it uh
benefits and advertising all of which go
to support um our our products and
certainly um that's all I had Mr
chairman I as you can imagine our budget
is very simple we don't get grants we
don't get Federal money we don't get
donations it's and that you know I would
like to point out that we spend from our
Revenue stream so it's not really a
budget item if you cut us there's not
really a saving somewhere to go
someplace
else because it'll just go as profit for
m to the education trust fund thank you
that yeah yeah just so we're clear
that's what we hear about by the same to
I would submit that over the last number
of years we've never spent our budget
never even come close to spending our
budget so we acted like grown-ups so I'd
ask that to take it into consideration
and not punish us because that's all I
um you know record profit growth is not
that easy to
do so just to inform the committee of
how Lottery's budget typically works in
the past when doing it in division Ways
and Means will come up with a revenue
estimate which they've uh gone through
that process that is really what's going
to impact your bottom line for Education
trust fund uh historical
practices if you make a reduction in
Lottery commissions operating budget
here or make an ad like the two that
they've requested here that wouldn't
change anything we we would look at this
as other funds the revenue estimate is
done separate so Lottery will provide a
revenue estimate to uh Ways and Means
and they'll look at it as that's what
they'll bring in based on the budget
that Lottery asks for so when we if for
instance it would be a new practice for
this committee which not saying it's
it's in the purview of this committee
you can do whatever you want to do if
you were to reduce a class line by
$50,000 we wouldn't necessarily carry
something on the Surplus statement
adding $50,000 to the education trust
fund how about a million
dollars again that's up to the committee
if you want to do no I'm just asking
would what would you do if even even $5
would be up to the committee to do I'm
just letting you know historical
practice with how we've done the lottery
budget this committee can do whatever
you want to do but I'm just letting you
know how it's worked in the past
okay thank you Mr chair first I want to
assure you that we pay close attention
to who the grown-ups are in terms of the
agencies and we appreciate agencies that
show the discipline and we make sure
that we don't punish them for not
spending their budget by cutting their
budget right so we're just talking about
what's truly needed and genuinely
understanding the needs of the agencies
and we appreciate you know everything
you guys uh do but second at the end of
the day every dollars you guys don't
spend whether we recognize it early in
the budget process or not we'll end up
you know you know if it doesn't affect
Revenue right any additional profit will
be reflected in the education trust fund
which is not the general fund but it's
still very real money that goes for real
real purposes
so in the past uh we may have had a more
relaxed thing in terms of the self
funding agencies we are trying really
hard to look in detail of everybody
because every dollar counts it's going
to be a really tough budget and I'm sure
you've heard this a 100 times I don't
want this to be more than a
1001st but we do appreciate it we are
very careful about we ask but this is
why we ask so many questions to
understand what's reasonable and what's
not because the last thing we want to do
is kill the goods with the golden eggs
right to that point I I appreciate the
comment representative and one of the
difficult difficulties is is in this
budget environment for example we're
expecting another slew not
slw several other gaming operations to
come online during the next bium and
so it's a difficult proposition to
simultaneously grow and
contract and so I have to M and you
folks want us to manage and regulate all
these rooms and as you as you should and
so I know asking to fund more positions
at the time when other agencies are
cutting back is a difficult suggestion
is just I also want to do my job and our
job and regulate these rooms effectively
so that certainly there's a there's a
rubbing Point somewhere that hits but
that's certainly I'd like to
mention so I will want you to speak to
some of those future things but we'll
come back to that representative Murray
thank you very much yeah I propo the
upcoming bium there are two really big
holes here um one is um the slots coming
on the I forget what it's called The V
whatever they're just slots so there are
slots coming on um in her budget um
which has not gone to Ways and Means
hasn't gone to the house and I'm really
concerned about this little room here um
dealing with a larger issue and there's
a big gap in terms of you know I guess
over the bayning there's 127 million 17
I think 107 yeah in the second one 100
there you're expecting 117 million in
2017 the other big hole is the gap
between what the governor thinks you're
going going to do in what ways and means
thinks is reasonable those are really
really big gaps and so I appreciate some
of the concerns about let's you know be
consistent or let's be conservative and
careful with our money um but these are
two big gaping holes and how what do you
what what are your thoughts on this I'm
afraid to say how would you address this
because that's not necessarily your job
but um how do we reconcile that if I can
take the second part
first um the revenue estimates that are
derived and Ways and Means are done by
my colleague and I very early in the
process and candidly as you can imagine
in the fall of last year um we take a
very conservative Viewpoint of what we
expect revenues to be and
so and that updates over time and um the
governor and I spoke about Revenue
estimates for the out
tanium and a couple of things hadn't
happened that we anticipated happening
one is sports betting launching in
Massachusetts hasn't had quite the
impact we anticipated on sports betting
Revenue second more rooms that we
anticipated and the large size of them
as well as the profitability of them
surprised even me like for example the
historic horse racing machines we did a
revenue estimate that these would be
essentially $150 a day gross profit
which we all split but we get a take
they're actually at $239 per machine per
day currently so significantly more than
we anticip ipated and so uh when the
governor asked you know can we look at
the revenue estimates we took another
look at them and that's where the number
comes from the 185 it doesn't come from
the governor it came from us having a
conversation and coming up with and
particularly where this year is ending
up I think in terms of plan we're at 168
for this year and I think we're trending
more like 185
186 so as you can
imagine it's a very difficult
proposition to Revenue estimate out two
years when I don't know or my colleague
doesn't know what the gas prices are
going to be or whether the Middle East
is going to blow up or supply chain X or
Y is going to be a problem and so it's a
we try and error on the side of caution
but certainly for us um that's where the
185 comes from and in terms of VT
Revenue I think the disparity is in
terms of what the percentage that the
state will get as part of its rev share
if that activity is authorized So
currently under historic horse racing
the state and charity split 25% of the
revenue and The Operators get 75% under
the governor's budget that split would
go from to 55% for The Operators and 45%
to the state and the Charities so it's a
matter of you're getting a larger piece
of the pie essentially because the pie
itself will grow
significantly so sorry that answer your
question oh sorry per just as a point of
clar clarification though my
understanding is that the split between
the education trust fund and the general
fund uh once that um shift and revenue
distribution happens is that less of the
proportion will come to the education
trust fund it'll be split 5050 at that
point so the my favorite part of my job
is we just make the money
and so literally it comes to here in a
barrel we drop it off and back away
slowly and so how how it get spent by
the folks who elected is really as I
often say we we don't make policy
instruments of policy so um that is for
decide represent papovich thank you you
were talking and thank you for uh you
know answering again all these questions
um you were talking about the
differences in timing between your
Revenue estimates that were used by ways
and
means I'm a bit confused because
obviously you started early so your
original numbers had to be more
conservative and less recent but as the
governor Works through it doesn't Ways
and Means also refine their numbers and
then why do we do you do you have any
idea as to why do we still have a
significant discrepancy because I get it
between full estimates and spring
estimates but all of them are now
February estimates so do you do you have
any certainly that's um a matter of us
being conservative honestly if I can
suggest
the Christmas time period and the time
after Christmas are telling us to what
we believe revenues would look like for
the year uh Christmas is our busiest
week week after Christmas is our second
busiest week and the weeks thereafter
our worst weeks and so um we don't like
to change our Revenue estimates through
that period and so for us it was a
matter of last minute not last minute
but certainly the most recent
revisitation of it and the fact that we
were more comfortable six months seven
months through the year than we were two
months through the year ESS EV yeah
that's it's a matter of timing and and I
don't I don't we Jim really doesn't like
to overperform promise
underperform it's because then because
one of the difficulties of this job and
I would hearken to this is once you put
it in the budget it's already
spent like and so if we don't make it
it's it's an unpleasant conver call call
from people like what and so that's
there's a we share that philosophy where
we'd rather have a bit of a safety
margin rather than go over the limb and
fall off by an inch or two I have been
in the room with very uncomfortable
conversations with governors in the past
and it's unpleasant I'd rather avoid it
you know just candidly I'd rather not
thank you yeah R Mar thank you again uh
so you know back to two things your
conservative estimates are still I guess
Ways and Means is way more conservative
than their estimates than you are
they're estimating you know the 12 and
your or they're estimating um you're
estim ating 12 million more than what
way and means so they're when you say
it's a conservative estimate it's like
yeah but way and means is more
conservative that does not address the
Gap and the other thing is can we you
Circle back around to actual slot
machines I understand the historic
racing but this is a major change to go
from the historic whatever I don't even
understand it to slots okay so the the
the conservative estimate is 173 that's
ours to Ways and Means and the 185 to us
is what we anticipate would be a
reasonable estimate so it's both of
those of our numbers just based on
dates yeah and certainly to VTS I would
not characterize as a major seismic
change and the reason I suggest this is
because the historic ory
machines nothing's going to changes how
they look very little the cabling's
still there the cameras are still there
the box is going to look the same it's
literally going to be the same box
you're just changing out the content
within it and the math behind it uh and
so it's not a well I understand the the
word may sound like their big change if
you walked in and on a Monday and they
changed it to next Friday you would
notice very little difference and it's
just the player likes it a lot better um
VTS versus HHR and that's for the that's
the reason for the revenue estimate and
the revenue being
raised so are you expecting more people
to play or you the same number of people
to play on the same machines are you
expecting more people to play on the
same machines are you expecting how many
more machines cuz we're going up to
4,000 now if you don't see a big
difference between the historic racing
and the salt machines so I it's a
physical difference versus a play
difference right and
so the way it plays the machines do
better financially I anticipate both
individuals to play more as well as more
people to come play because right now
there's a large number of people
traveling to Boston and Springfield and
plan Ridge and migan sun and Foxwoods um
because the product in New Hampshire is
not the same as the product there I
anticipate more of them to come up here
and I would expect particularly in the
southern rooms Nash
Salem you know all on the southern
border they place there not by accident
that 2/3 to three quarters will be Mass
residents I'm sorry my so are you still
are you suggest I'm trying to understand
this from like a um a public perspective
point of view um it sounds like there's
a difference between historic horse
racing and slot machines um there are
people who are supportive of one but
when you bring up that they're slot
machines then all of a sudden there's a
group of people who dig in their heels
and say we did not approve that um I'm
sure remember with Kino communities had
the option to accept Kino into their
Community or not I don't think they had
the option with the historic horse
racing and I'm not sure um where this
would end up with and I'm still
surprised that we're discussing it
instead of ways and
means y
um I'm not sure that I I answer that
question yeah yeah
sorry okay all right no it's Sly I'm you
know we're subject I'm a subject man
expert on gaming and so I can submit to
you as terms of the math behind it and
if you want but in terms of policy
decisions regarding who gets to approve
yeah ha yeah so let's talk about the
math um I should disclose that I'm a
lawyer by trade and so math is always
something I have to do on a calculator
it's not my most comfortable subject in
life but um you know if I'm looking at
um the projected
Revenue um I'm trying to find where my
little page is um yeah yeah so 120
million by the end
of right by the end of 27
and6 is that right am I reading wrong oh
no sorry 58.5 million at the end of 27
um for revenues on
video VTS
um so if you do the math that's about is
that right if there's
58.5% Revenue coming to the state at the
end of 27 wouldn't that mean like a
total revenue of more like
400 yeah it's more than that okay so if
you I don't want to know what number
numbers you have in front of your
representative so I AP oliz I'm talking
off of my memory I'm just looking at the
unrestricted
revenues
okay if I may that that number is half
because you're looking at either general
fund or okay or education trust it's
really 117 million is the governor's
estimate in FAL 27 okay so yeah so 127
if you do the breakdown it'd be more
like
over4 400 million toal it's more than in
terms of the overall so like the gross
before you do the distribution to the
ETF so if I could sort of roll it up a
second so there's what's called handle
which is activity and then there's gross
revenue which is money that's left in
the tail at the end of the day and then
there's what our share is which is a
percentage of that uh and so we did our
Revenue Investments based off of what
the machine revenue is in similar
jurisdictions in the same growth pattern
given the same Marketplace and so
essentially um
our revenue estimat is based off of
$300 a day what is known as win per unit
per day right what's left in the machine
I think it was approximately 4,400
machines being up and running by FY 27
for 365 days and so if you do that math
it should yield you somewhere
around 270 million I
think I'm like I said you know I'm a
lawyer too by training so I leave the
math to my col colleague here but um 300
unit per day is a pretty standard like
Boston right now is over $400 per unit
Per Day Rhode Island is a 293 per win
per unit per day Maine which has nobody
living near it is around $250 win per
unit per day so $300 we assumed was
actually a pretty legitimate number and
so that's what it's based on it's the
increased product sorry I'm just
thinking ahead if you divide that total
Revenue by 1.4 million people in our
state that means like everybody gambles
more than $200 a year
right uh no so as I said before um if
you drive into any of the parking lots
of our so as I believe the best kind of
money is out estate money and so most of
the facilities are on the border
intentionally like there's one in North
Conway On the Border one in Keane On the
Border one in Lebon On the Border Salem
On the Border two on nro On the Border
like Portsmith On the Border like the
idea being is they are so I did this
math when I there was a casino Bill if
you put a pinhole in plast out I choose
plast out randomly nothing just plast
out and you create an hour driving
distance which is the standard by which
casino driving is measured on the south
half of that circle is 1.5 1.6 million
people on the north of half of that is
500,000 people and so the vast majority
of play will drive to New Hampshire
is my is is my estimates geography
doesn't care about I mean I'm sorry
retail Behavior doesn't care about
geography it's the same logic with
liquor if you believed with liquor sold
we'd all be drunks constantly and so the
majority of liquor sales come from
another state um so the same logic
applies sure and I think Mr chair if you
just indulge me I think um what we're
discussing right now is a pretty big
cultural shift of the way people in our
region will game so um it sounds like
more people from not New Hampshire are
going to be here engaging in this new
activity so um I just if if we're really
not
anticipating um New Hampshire
citizens participating in this um new
activity as much as out of Staters then
I think again this is really something
Ways and Means should be discussing
because it sounds like a pretty big
cultural societal shift that um we're
we're entertaining right now know this
hypothetical
so representative D thank you for
answering all these questions of course
you do you see a big shift in Revenue
income coming in in the summertime when
all of the tourists are here andan can
you see a pattern that happens of people
waving into New Hampshire all this money
coming and then the wave going back out
does that make sense to you it do it
does it's an excellent question and um
when we had sports betting and mass
didn't
it was massive Portsmith liquor store
and the Nashville liquor store were the
two biggest hot spots for sports betting
probably North
America you would literally they would
drive there grab a b a couple of bottles
and bet while they were in Nashua
because they were in New Hampshire you
could bet an that New Hampshire uh we
don't have that anymore we sell very
very similar products to all of our
neighbors and so we don't have the
massive shifts you will get an uptick in
certain regions like the Lakes region
does uptick in the summer uh but not
globally
Statewide pH just one more question Mr
chair I'm wondering if the assumption is
that currently the folks who hold these
charitable horse um historical horse R
Racing permits are they all are you
assuming that they will all adjust to
the new
VT machines or because my understanding
is that um um the investment in those
new machines was fairly recently so um
are are they all willing to just make
the jump to the to the new activity or
is is that not your assumption so it is
my assumption and it was based off a
conversation with virtually every single
one of them and the time period as I
asked all of them what the time period
would be to switch um the investment
while significant is not lost most of
the machines can be
converted uh and it's a it's a small
it's a not a small charge because I'm
not paying it uh it's $3 to $4,000 per
machine to convert uh and
so the Zeal in which they've asked me
adopt so I'd like to sort of understand
what's going on here in terms of the the
way this comes to pass because I'm not
very familiar with the whole thing did
you did
the can the Lottery Commission just
decide to add new like this the VT thing
or can you just sort of explain that
part of Works certainly um even if we
could I we wouldn't uh we want to make
sure uh like for example there was an
opinion from the AG's office that we
didn't need legislative approval to pass
Kino we still waited for you folks to
file a bill and pass it and have the
governor sign it only because I don't
want to step out in front of the state
in terms of gaming practice and gaming
policy so it would have to come from you
folks to say well HHR is a very
different product than the LTS and it
would require a legislative change in
order to make that happen that's my
short answer so I remember all the H
over over the horse Ring Thing and and
voting on that have we voted on this on
the V we have not no so it exists in
three forms Mr chairman uh there's a
house bill there's a Senate bill and
then it's contained within HB one and
two of the governor's budget so it is
and two okay so it's literally three
places um and I don't know what which
version oh I don't know where that bill
is but so it's an hb2 as well as the
other places that's how the governor
covered her Bas correct yeah so there's
literally it's all three places at once
and they're all different versions of
the same what was the house bill number
do you know I it's House Bill
728 thank yeah and we did go over this
if you remember a couple days ago when
we went through the trailer bill it is
in it is in here than you and just to
revisit the process so house Ways and
Means will take up House Bill 728 they
haven't had a public hearing yet and
they'll have a um report filed on that
bill and that will align still with your
timeline of the budget so this committee
could wait for the house policy to be
set on VTS uh and then you could
override anything in House Bill too with
what the house passes if you so chose or
you could let it be its own stand
Standalone pieace of legislation and
historical practice like we had
mentioned earlier this week is policy
related items in House Bill 2 house
finance has parse those out to the
policy committees for review so this
would should should be a house a Ways
and Means task to come up with a
decision on this not necessarily this
committee what we would want to consider
is if the house position is to authorize
maybe check back with Lottery to see
would they need any changes to their
operating budget to align with the
program repr
papich thank you just to follow up on
what Mr landrian just said I just want
to check that as of now based on what's
in hb2 everything is consistent we are
just worried about potentially the house
amending or doing something to the
legislation that's not current but we
are up to date right now in terms of the
revenue projections versus the legal
language in hb2 HB 728 correct the only
thing we're not up to date on I think
our positions that would be added to it
if this was authorized and I believe it
was in our fiscal note
for uh it was the Senate version we put
FAL note but other than that yes if it's
in a fiscal note it's there I mean we'll
worry about it if the bill passes and so
exactly yeah it's well down the road of
you representative Kelly All We thanks
thank you I'm kind of naive about this
but how much of this is internet is my
assumption was that sports betting was
internet um is
ey lottery so um thank you for the
question um and I wish you were better
I'm clear not you're not one of our
customers clearly uh I'm so I'm so bad
that after the Big Jack jackpot it's the
day after that I say oh so really our
internet Revenue comes from two main
sources um about 85% of the activity for
sports betting is done mobile
internet about 85% 15% is done retail so
our Sports books our physical Sports
books there's four of them that 15%
happens there um and then I Lottery is
100% through the internet and that
includes a number of things like you
could buy a Powerball ticket through the
internet you could buy a Mega Millions
ticket through the internet uh you know
bad snowstorm that obviously spikes
because folks can play but they don't
have to leave their house uh and you can
buy scratch tickets that are interactive
on their phone as well so that I Lottery
um net win is essentially that's all ey
that that's right that's right so as a
followup how do you U monitor what is
out of state and sales and what is in
state sales both of the platforms have
robust products on them um that's
governed by a company called geoc comply
which geofences the
state um border and so if you are on or
near the border uh the wager is blocked
uh the algorithm is so sophisticated if
you're on 89 driving West and you were
going to cross the Connecticut River
before you finish your wager The Wager
will time out it will know you're going
so many miles per hour The Wager is
going to take so many seconds and the
wager will time out so and it the entire
universe tested this those that are
opposed to us doing this and they found
no holes in our
system repr papovich just to add a
little bit to it as somebody who may
have had a draft King's account
it's quite annoying because sometimes I
swear to God I am inside the Border but
the damn phone doesn't trust me it's
very Twitchy near the border it is very
hard you know the Geo fencing is very
strict I don't think we'll have
compliance because again you guys have
Federal Regulators you have all the kind
of regulators breathing down your necks
if you dare plus Massachusetts would
throw a Feit if you try to sell you know
to allow beds to be placed while
somebody's got forb in Massachusetts so
yeah I could the the biggest problem we
had was when we launched sports betting
there are two sports bars in Portsmith
one that's well Inland and then one
that's on the border of the pascatore
river and 350 ft was the distance that
was safe for us to say if you're within
350 ft and that sports bar couldn't take
Sports Wagers and the entire patrons
went up and left and went to the sports
bar and the owner of that sports bar
called and was Furious we had to carve
out this one spot on the map for the
sports bar that now okay they're they're
clearly in Portsmith but they're too
close to P Paso River to uh so it's a
very robust product that maintains our
um
geofence of course silly but with all
the sports betting that goes on you have
it I don't bet so I'm not familiar with
all this stuff but I know all of my
family is doing Bing online with their
Sports and what have you do we get any
of that Revenue if people are betting
here here in New Hampshire on say Kansas
or we get a portion of that so yes um we
get the a very large portion of it um by
the way you asked me for free tickets
nobody plays in here
just that's
not um so um sports betting we are
actually the number two state in the
country per capita for sports betting
revenue for the State uh behind New York
only um every bet placed in every bet
placed in New Hampshire we get a
percentage of that Revenue we split it
with DraftKings but it's around 43% of
the profit uh we
get so we have we have what most
characterizes as an exceptionally
enviable deal um and moreover DraftKings
is as our vendor partner moved one of
their offices to nsha and hired uh 20
software developers who work out of an
office in nashille and as n Corporation
so not only do they are vendor part
they've actually become a business in
fans papovich well it's kind of nice not
to have an income tax and sales taxes
and all that but um the other point to
be made is that people will gamble
anyway it's better that they do it in a
properly regulated manner above board
where they have legal recourse cuz God
knows if my uh friendly bookie who I
called on Friday night doesn't quite
remember remember the conversation the
same way I do I cannot exactly go to the
judge while with you know all this it's
so heavily regulated it's safe it gives
people a lot of confidence and we do
spend a lot of money to put it into
resources to help people who may have an
addiction issue and what not if I recall
if you have any details on that yeah I
mean certainly we technology is the easy
part because we can set limits um on how
much you can deposit you yourself can
set limits which I find to be more
effective if you yourself have a have
you know you have an issue you can set
limits or you can self-exclude we have a
very large not very large I think it's a
couple thousand people now that are on
exclusion list that say close my account
don't take money from me also the call
centers are trained to look for certain
words so for example on a Monday if
somebody says oh I need to win tonight
in order to pay my bills there can't
their account is disabled uh because we
don't we try and protect folks from
themselves to the extent you can um and
give them the rules to make it happen um
so the short answer is yes and as a
former organized crime prosecutor I can
tell you with a certainty approaching
death and taxes that sports betting went
here
so any other
questions everybody good and you didn't
both thank you for your
patience learned a lot and I really
appreciate it Mr chair Mr chair there is
a section in the trailer bill it's that
boiler play language it's in the back of
house Bill W about the so that went from
6 million to 15 million there's an
increase to that certainly I apologize I
should have spoken to that um there's
specific language that authoriz us to
buy scratch tickets it's been there
since the 70s uh and the amount hasn't
changed in well since I've been here at
six million a year we've exceeded that
annually and LBA audit team has pointed
that out and so we were looking to
increase the amount it doesn't change
anything in the budget it's just an
ability to increase what we buy from
scratch tickets during the bayum and so
that's the language it literally just
changes 6 million to 15 million it
doesn't change anything
else and that's in increasing the number
the amount of scratch tickets you can
purchase no it's actually just
increasing the amount we're allowed to
do even though and I hate to say this
we've we spent more than that annually
uh because we've increased scratch
ticket sales from almost doubled it the
last 10 years and so we're buying more
scratch tickets and we're more
profitable at them so the cost has gone
up and so so does the increase in the
number scat ticket you buy exactly yeah
exactly and it's not a it's not an
expense of the the budget like it's not
a yeah no I understand yeah yeah it's
just literally just a we have because
we're buying way more we have to
increase the number the authorization
that's all
got it correct yeah it's more yeah so
that's hb1 and then hb2 has a language
authorizing the video the video gaming
it does yes to begin with okay and um
there's something else about that that
language the video gaming oh represent
Murray raised the question
about the town cities whatever having um
any ability to to regulate it so the
with the which one was it that they
could it was could Kino so Kino that was
part of the law that said they could
well it's actually to that point uh it's
more than just Kino it's Kino and sports
betting and when the lottery was
originally founded in 1963 towns and
cities were allowed to say no to selling
lottery tickets um about I think
10ed um but yes so that's those
Provisions exist in those three areas
but not in the VT Bill uh I know there's
a I think there's a bill filed to have
the towns have an option going forward
um I don't remember the number but it's
okay okay but not an hp2 in any H2 no no
so it it mirrors what's going on with
the horse correct fting approach does it
mirrors what horse racing horse racing
allowed yeah thank you so I guess maybe
we're really done now are you fine set
okay thank you very much both of you
[Music]
okay
e